[Music]
okay everybody i'm really excited today
because
i am joined by the one the only jessica
aka natalie on amazon prime videos new
series panic
jessica how you doing today hey i'm
great
thank you so much for having me oh no i
i'm so excited to talk to you i'm a huge
fan of yours and before we even get into
this happy belated birthday i know
you're just telling me
so that's exciting oh that's really
sweet thank you
oh no problem and i'm not kissing up at
all i'm just i had to say it
no no no it literally just happened it's
very
you're on the money it's it's thank you
thank you
you know i i think of these things and
and it's exciting because it's exciting
to see you in the series because there's
a lot of fresh faces around you in the
cast and it actually seems like you're
like a vet there
i know that's crazy to say but like did
you ever feel like on set you took on
like a mentor role at any point
i mean it is funny portraying
somebody at this point on going on
a little bit younger than me emphasis on
little
um and i think everybody
like olivia is so just
like such a great captain of the ship
like a great leader
like has sets a lovely tone on set she's
approachable and kind and funny
and everyone was really kind
and lovely and you know in a way this
was like
i you know i've been working and sort of
trucking along but this is my first time
where i felt like i was like really part
of a
like shooting for a long period of time
the last time i had this sense of
camaraderie was in like recovery road
um but this was away in texas so being
in another location was also an
added element but that's really sweet uh
i did i always feel like i don't know
anything
so i will take that good perfect no
you know more than you think and that's
interesting too is um
is there knowing that you're it's a show
that's targeted towards young adults
is there a different approach as an
artist when you're
performing a role in the show like that
like do you is that conscious in your
head at all or is that not really
something you think about
yeah what i love about film and
television
and just anything in general is like
figuring out
genres and tones that's always fun and
like knowing
where it where the like where
everything's like what it's playing up
into
you know so i don't know like growing up
in
wales and just watching like cool
american teens go it was definitely
fun to play with that um and at the same
time i think
everybody on the show is super talented
and we always wanted to be
as grounding as possible with all of the
scenes because sometimes you're dealing
with content where you're like
wow i really have to put myself in this
headspace when it's like not a reality
but you just have to make it one
and just be as like natural as possible
with it
so it was fun challenge yeah no and you
crush it and
it's interesting you fit the part of
natalie perfectly but i wonder
was there any other parts you read for
besides natalie or were you always going
to be
natalie well i had done i think i'd done
a pilot for amazon like
the year prior when panic was actually
shooting it was like the three
like it was called college and there was
like the wilds and panic
and um yeah i i like i didn't i
i couldn't read for it because we were
filming at the same time and then a year
goes by and you know it's back in pilot
season you're hoping you get something
and the and the role came round and
you know you read the script and you
think this is really fun
and would be cool and i've worked with
amazon before
so that's nice um you gotta just
hope for the best uh so
yeah i was kind of it was kind of crazy
that i ended up working
with them again on this and it was funny
because like our group chat
for the last pilot were like jesse got
booked by amazon again
um it was like it was i was just so
happy to even get a call back after i
read the script because it seemed like a
lot of fun when i was like reading the
breakdown of what it was about
no that's cool too because i feel like
streaming services have their own fan
base too that recognized from show to
show they do
they really do and like um these are
really
really kind yeah hell yeah and uh
i also wonder too because this show is
absolutely wild
and i'm wondering is there anything in
your life you ever went through similar
to something like the game of panic like
in school or any
kind of like competition i
i mean i think honestly just
sometimes i look back at
going through something like skins at
such a young age
and i think that that was pretty crazy
you know i
we literally all lived alone in a hotel
in like bristol at the ages of like 16
and got to just like
run about and play and do really great
like misbehave
um and then you know i just
you know it's up and down like doing
this kind of job
and there was like a lot of bumps in the
road and i decided to just move to new
york when i was
you know 18 and like worked in like
restaurants and tried to figure
my [ __ ] out so that i think is you know
the element of survival and with and
challenging yourself
that i think is kind of crazy because
when i was i was talking to a friend's
mom
she was like oh my god i would never let
my kid just move to new york by
themselves at 18
and i was like well i know what but it
didn't even feel like
anything that was out of the question so
i suppose i suppose just
normal life yeah no and that's good you
have some experience in that kind of
wild
atmosphere because it just shows in your
performance you can kind of
go to that um before i let you go
jessica
my last question for you is in this
crowded world of streaming content for
someone watching this
why should they give panic a shot
i think at this present moment how i've
been sort of describing it is like
do you want a distraction from reality
do you want a little bit of escape
i think this is fun enough where you can
just
check out and just have a good time with
these kids
trying to figure out life um
and you know it's like it's this the
you can relate because it's the small
town but then it's
also so ridiculous in the best way
yeah that's perfect uh everyone you
heard it from herself
make sure to watch panic on amazon prime
video may 28th
you will be hooked literally right from
episode one trust me when i say that
jessica thank you so much for joining me
and i hope to talk to you in the future
i hope so too you've been the the best
super kind and lovely thank you
thank you you're the best happy birthday
thank you